the pace of covet vaccinations in the
u.s is
steadily rising according to the cdc
more than 27 million americans have now
gotten at least
one shot but some rural areas in
virginia are being left behind
because of how the process is designed
our lead national correspondent david
begno traveled to wise county in the
southwestern
part of the state david good morning
anthony good morning to you appalachia
couldn't be prettier or
poorer in some places we came here to
tell the story of what is essentially
the little guy
asking for a seat at the table
healthwagon has been servicing this part
of the area for decades and they give
their services
for free some of these patients are coal
miners they have black lung disease
there are tons of pre-existing
conditions among people who live here
they are among the most vulnerable in
the united states
and they have not gotten a single dose
of the vaccine
y'all wear your mask and stay safe okay
the heart of appalachia
beats with the help of nurse
practitioner teresa tyson
how long did you work in the mines
32 years 32 years she runs the
healthwagon
the mobile medical clinic providing
crucial health care to low income and
underserved people here in southwestern
virginia
they don't have reliable transportation
they don't have the money for fuel to go
to a clinic
for 28 years nurse teresa has navigated
these rural roads of appalachia
to service those who otherwise may not
get any medical care
what they need now she says is the
vaccine
the healthwagon services two health
districts in the state
those districts account for about two
percent of virginia's population
and this week they received about 2100
doses
out of the approximately 120 000
vaccines
allocated to the state now that's just
under two percent
we are trying to get that healthwagon
which has more than 5600
active patients has not gotten a single
dose
instead they've gone to mostly local
hospitals local health departments and
long-term care facilities i'm just
desperate to get the vaccine for my
people
we went to dr danny avula the state's
vaccine coordinator
he told cbs news there is not enough
doses coming from the federal government
to distribute to everyone who wants it
a month or two months from now as new
vaccines come on the scene
we'll be able to start feeding all of
these channels of providers and
pharmacies who can get out the vaccine
at large scale as of today virginia is
deciding who gets vaccines
based on population but nurse teresa
says that's not fair
appalachia is more rural but the need is
enormous
vulnerable populations need to be a
priority in receiving this vaccine
they have chronic health conditions they
actually live 10 years
less than our counterparts on the
eastern shore of virginia
and they're poorer here healthwagon says
the poverty rate of the area its
services
is 54 percent higher than the rest of
virginia
is there something you can do to get
vaccines here for them
quick absolutely it's called more doses
he is virginia's governor ralph northam
who himself is a doctor
right now david we're getting about a
hundred and twenty thousand doses a week
we need about 350 000. most of what i
heard is
teresa is doing great work but she just
needs to be patient
what do you say oh my gosh i can't be
patient i have to be a voice for the
people that do not have a voice here
how can you be patient in a pandemic
when people are dying
bottom line west virginia needs more
doses from the federal government most
states do or the states need to be able
to buy directly from the pharmaceutical
companies
let me be fully transparent when the
governor of virginia found out we were
coming
here his staff called cbs news and said
the governor wanted to be a part of the
story
i interviewed him and i thought he was
going to say he was sending doses here
he didn't but gail nurse teresa is
optimistic she says with the governor
now on notice so to speak
he knows what they need and she thinks
he'll help get something here
soon i think she has a point i i think
she has a really good point where she
said how can you be patient in a
pandemic
people are dying and you're afraid thank
you david but something tells me the
governor will figure something out
sooner rather than
later thank you